oh hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to subnautica now by
some amazing stroke of luck with the
official full release of this game my
save game file still works which means
that I am in a great position in the
middle of the ocean surrounded by
nothing but death and only darkness
awaits me but this is the full release
of the game this is what I've been
waiting for this is what we've all been
waiting for because now we can get the
hell off of this damn ocean planet
number one I need to get back to my [ __ ]
which is way over there big box berries
in the ocean what is that well I have a
new message I'm sure there's gonna be
good hello okay alright then well that
sucks for them they can suck a big old
donger because I ain't gonna come their
way and I'm pretty sure they're dead no
matter what happens now where we are I'm
not 100% sure but bubble butt is right
there which means that we have a mode of
transportation and things don't look so
dire but number one I gotta say before I
start anything I'm really happy that
this game is fully released I was
tempted to start over all over again I
really was to play for the beginning but
I've already done that and I've come so
far in this one and I've taken so much
time and patience to be able to do this
that I've kind of gotten to this point
where I'm in love with the game I really
am I hate the ocean oh don't get me
wrong I hate the ocean and we're gonna
have to explore a lot of stuff that
we've seen already anyway and I'm gonna
set out some objectives that we got to
do but it is good to be back it is
really really good to be back it's good
to see this game finally released
they've done tons of optimizations to
the game they've made it polished
they've actually fully released it with
the storyline all intact everything on
the Aurora that is able to be gone
he's available over there which means
that number one I'm gonna go back to the
Aurora number two I'm gonna retrieve all
my [ __ ] number three I'm gonna start
farming up materials and number four we
are gonna launch e the heli out of here
here we are gonna launch e the heli out
of here we've got our mobile vehicle bae
over with jeffrey billy Sam Weiss and
Marshall I remember doze off at the top
my head I didn't even need to look him
up Geoffrey Billy Samwise and Marshall
they're over there by the ship in our
first base that we built in the shadow
of the aurora so what I'm gonna do right
now is I'm gonna retrieve everything
that we have I'm gonna go back to the
sea Emperor's place because apparently
I'm not cured if I take off this glove
year let me show you something it's
horrible but uh let myself scan I guess
Oh
yep I'm infected which if I recall I was
not that way before not under percent
sure but I don't remember exactly where
we left off and I wasn't bothered to be
checked so maybe we can't hit that on
the way back
whoa hey an animation we got a
temperature room why do we have a
temperature reading is there some
dynamic where well oh it's getting night
oh [ __ ] that went quit way whoa whoa
whoa whoa oh oh oh my god that is so
cool holy [ __ ] I mean I think I know it
did that before but it didn't do that so
dramatically that it's an eclipse of the
goddamn everything oh my goodness gravy
hey let me stand them up a book oh that
is so pretty we got stuff to do number
one first and foremost we got to take
care of this disease which means that we
got to go back all the way to the sea
emperor's container and in the sea
emperor's container lies to see emperor
babies and in the sea emperor babies lie
I got a drink my piss here Peter within
the sea Emperor babies lies the cure to
the kirara virus which means that we
won't die if we take those so I am
assuming that we got to take the sea
Emperor babies crack them open like a
like a lobster and slurp out the sweet
delicious cure from their delicious
innards
that or we need to like pet him and wait
for them to poop and then to eat their
poop even one I'm willing to take either
I'm not exactly picky right now because
I'm about to die
but first and foremost got to go down
there and I guess we could hit this
light pot on the way down I better not
be near anything dastardly don't seem
too bad going into the couch zone here I
don't remember this one it's beamed
hello hi was that what I think it was
Hey Hey back you the heck Yaffe I don't
have my defence modules on this and I
don't have my big punkin Cyclops
you stay away have I been to you before
hey see pot twelve can you hear me
no survivors it's not that going in here
don't kill me okay fine hello a band
arrived yeah that's scary
alright abandon PDA oh yeah
medical officer Oh I'm a doctor I know
that's what my ID says but I never have
been cheating the medical exams what
does the doctor these days need to know
about manually resetting bones when was
the last time a top surgeon actually cut
someone open that's what the robots are
for doctors these days read diagnoses
off of computer readouts that I'm
perfectly qualified I'm not connected to
the main network I'm bleeding I've got
glowing green pustules growing on my
hands I run a self scan and it tells me
I got skin irritation the only thing I
studied in medical school was how to lie
convincingly what the hell do I know
about how to treat an alien disease I
think I'm actually going to die go
you might be you might be considering
the fact that you're not here I'm
assumed that you is already dead sure
maybe you shouldn't have sat yourself
next to a volcano oh that's right the
geothermal generator that is excessively
important okay but we're near where we
need to be whew
oh that's a volcano yeah you're clear
huh Sharky screaming we lose them in the
tunnels I'm just like Han Solo in the
now this is podracing Hey yeah I did I
missed you
did you miss me I bet you didn't though
you're gonna know Hey Wow I don't like I
don't like you
ah there it is okay so it should be on
if it's not on then I'm boned if it is
but it's on okay I'm not boned thought
I'd be boned not boned
dad is a scream hello I'm here I'm back
baby oh wait a minute you're still alive
no I don't want that I thought I've been
through this emotional trauma ah oh no I
don't know we do I have the hatching
enzymes then did I do all of that stuff
I don't remember what I did
insert ion cube okay yeah okay that
works now oh hi hey what's up amps are
you doing I don't have I don't have it
anymore
how do I not have it but I went through
all the trouble of getting that Oh No
there it is hatching enzymes I already
went through all the trouble I swear I
did I swear I went through all the
trouble I got every single thing and it
was a pitcher 1/2 oh my god and I don't
have it
son of a tit
well alright maybe I did a stupid like
bold blue gamma to be bold maybe I did a
stupid thing where I was like hey I'm
gonna not cheat but also this isn't
ready that sounds like me that sounds
like I was up my own ass about it I just
pissed myself I'm so scared of my true
nature okay all right shut up whatever
I'll just catch a people good I'm gonna
eat you the upper can't do nothing
Emperor can't protect you now okay right
you just go stuff you brighten my gob no
I'm straight up right in my belly yeah
you're right in front of the Emperor
what do you think of that there you come
here you peeper I like the way a giant
eyeball tastes when I crunch it alright
you stay safe hemp's I'm gonna pretend
like I don't know what happens and we're
gonna get ya do
and feels so bad Big M Big E oh my
goodness you're so beautiful
alright I'll be back I'll be back
alright we know what we need to do we
know what we need to do and I still hold
to the true values that I have no
cheating no cheating no nothing
because if I cheat e ib t myself with
the stick now I got to find these
hatching enzymes again which means that
I get to go in a little bit of an
adventure where am i where am i what day
[ __ ] just happened
Oh Bob oh boy
where did bubble butt go why was that
did it did like this did you like the
lavage how [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is that
seasons oh I don't like this I don't
like this at all
weird bubble buck oh hey hey hey hey hey
you [ __ ] you warper [ __ ] what are
you doing here listen you're not welcome
here I got to find bubble buddy where
the [ __ ] did go I don't even understand
what happened I think maybe I got
grabbed by Leviathan but did he destroy
bubble butt that quickly
what is that what's what's that over
there no that's a vent god dammit I am
dead if all of eyghon finds me I am just
straight-up dead why isn't this dark
still this is a bad place to be if that
was a Leviathan then it's not safe to be
here and look for bubble but I guess
I'll come back oh god damn it damn it it
was awful Oh boat was just ripped from
my arms what the hell happened
yeah okay you know that doesn't happen
you don't need to be a scary sack of
poop you just don't need to be that you
don't need to be that we may be able to
go find bubble butt but I'm not gonna
swim around those oceans with Leviathan
around if that's even what happened to
me I'm pretty sure that was a Leviathan
but again I'm just talking myself in
circles trying to rationalize what
happened either way I figure I lost
Bubble Boy which is bad because that was
my fastest method of transportation I'm
gonna have to make another one
I can't Bubble Boy Bubble Boy
[Music]
bo-buds with me through thick and thin I
get sad I'm legit sad about that I am
honestly sad bubble butts been with me
for so long power so glass lubricant LED
titanium and good I might have the
materials for this over in big box Barry
so let me go to big box Berg first conv
threw a wrench into all of my plans and
I know I can go back to my old save but
I don't want to do that like I don't
want to do that especially on the first
episode back on the main game cuz man
that is that sucks that sucks but it was
my own stupid fault I was I was going
right through the Reaper Leviathan
territory and I wasn't even paying
attention to where I was going
how did it even sneak up on me you're
supposed to be able to hear them and was
it even that maybe I just hit a rock and
I panic got out of my thing
but I'm pretty sure my my seamoth turned
around which means that I'm gonna get
over this I'm gonna get over to big box
Barry go back to my first place I'm
gonna meet up with Geoffrey Billy
Samwise and Marshall and we're gonna get
the heck out of here
Oh God look at all the names lapis eggs
swag bird lots of peeps ninja cat Robin
Haddix scoot max to Destructo shade 265
kotti wish on that and that's the thing
that I'm gonna enjoy most about getting
back to this game is being able to put
you guys whose names on here and if you
don't remember how to get your name on
here all you gotta do is comment down
some advice some words of encouragement
a joke that makes me laugh that's really
all they need and the fifth and then
we're gonna be back at business but we
have big box Barry alright so we got a
bunch of stuff a Ruby Ruby Ruby you're
an N tonight alright I don't remember
half of these materials because I don't
remember the icons of which they are man
everything looks so nice now okay so
we've got everything except for the lead
I know I've got LED somewhere in here I
am very confident in my lead I have yes
lead okay I've got LED I don't know if
that's enough
it is okay so we got everything that we
need for another engine offline well
there's a fire that thank you thank you
I don't think I ever named your voice
but I don't think you need a voice I
don't even want to give you a voice you
know what I don't care if it's
cavitating because I've got all the
defense mechanisms needed to not be able
to do anything
ooh there you go grumbling bumbly
they're overheating we gotta move fast
baby we got to get to where we gotta get
what are you gonna do blow up alright
fine you second kids where's my fire
signature do I have an amplifier I do
not have hi where's our fire hello Oh
glass not good yeah no joke no joke okay
all right okay all right cut the dubstep
okay it's fine it's fine everything's
fine what are you oh oh I could modify a
vehicle there ooh potatoes all right
that's fine so the lesson of the days
don't do that because that's who I am
so if I don't do that then I'm not gonna
have a problem and if I don't have a
problem then I ain't gonna be stupid and
if I ain't stupid I ain't gonna know
that both of my guys oh this bad oh okay
this is a bad idea this is what I call a
bad idea I need to dock no I need to
dock okay shield up sonar good break for
silent running oh we are in trouble okay
all right this rescue mission has gone
awry where's the way the gun doc I need
to get to the gun doc the gun doc there
there there there there there's a doc I
know you know there's a doc I've never
used it before knots on the other side
of this one okay it's going yeah I'm
still gonna use the doc just in case the
dubsteps really pounding today oh it's
the same sack of [ __ ] I bet that's the
same exact sack of [ __ ] that did it last
time
oh that
freaking [ __ ] okay I got to take care
of some stuff oh I gotta take care of
some stuff
okay well oh god that's not good my
potatoes oh no oh no oh no replace my
rings they were to take fire okay all
right so repair so that looks bad okay I
gotta go outside now okay I'll go repair
now okay
repairing repairing immediately now okay
oh how we looking geez that ass what did
a number on me I didn't think that it
could hurt me that badly I mean I know
I'm vulnerable now it's not like I'm
immune anymore but goddamn oh really
smack this [ __ ] out of me all right
crisis averted right he better not be
just sucking down power cuz if you are
I'm gonna be so pissed no I cannot move
what no wait a minute
I can't move excuse me what did you just
decide to reject me as your your captain
because what I wasn't doing a good
enough job protecting you huh
is that what it was oh you're out of
power oh okay all right
who is that all how are you out of power
oh my god what drained him are you
[ __ ] my dick here what the hell did
the shield really drain it that fast oh
my god are you kidding me that is like
the most power suck I've ever seen
why so much power suck is it because
it's charging now and like the toll
cheat of charging your thing from the
own thing it doesn't work anymore is
that what it is that is so much power I
don't like that okay that uses a lot of
power I just wasted more oh I'm so boned
oh I'm bone to the extreme oh I'm boned
oh I am oh oh
I guess they might have fixed the the
infinite power thing they probably did
they probably definitely fixed that I am
boned oh no okay well let's stop the
charging because I'm about to die again
stop stop and then stop stop stop stop
okay
all right Wow all right it's so unfair
you [ __ ]
you took a bubble but for me everything
I knew and loved is gone everything I
loved is gone everything I knew and
loved is gone I'm gonna run out of power
okay
all right I can do this it's fine we got
this so here's the plan
I've got I've got a new plan the next
few episodes are going to involve me
building a new base a brand new base
forget what the old is we're gonna bring
in a brand new base it's gonna be near
the aurora again because I know I'm
gonna have to go into the aurora for a
few more things before I finish this off
just to see everything that's in there
that's leftover but I'm gonna build a
new base it's gonna have a better power
system so that I can have the ion power
cells that I need to be able to flip out
the power for the Cyclops because I
guarantee they've gotten rid of the
unlimited energy thing that is gone I
don't even know if I can make it back to
my base with the amount of energy that I
have left and I probably can't because
it's draining fast right now so what I
need to do is I need to make a new base
and I need to go and survive that's all
I got to do I got to survive get the
materials for the hatching enzyme avoid
Reaper leviathans like the frickin
plague
and make it out here alive so it's gonna
be an adventure we're not through the
woods yet it's not as easy as just
hopping on a rocket and getting the hell
out of here even though I technically do
have the materials available to be able
to do that but I can't get those
hatching enzymes without bubble butt
gotta make bubble butt gotta get new
stuff gotta get power up and running and
it all starts with a brand new base so
that's what I'm gonna do in the next
episode so thank you everybody so much
for watching it let me know down in the
comments if you want to be on the next
Locker but only if you give me some cool
advice or make fun of me for all of my
flights that I've been through
thank you everybody again and as always
see you in the next video bye bye I
pissed myself
[Music]